hey leute und willkommen zur snapshot
review vom snapshot 12 w 41a wir
wahrscheinlich anhört bin ich wieder
gesund das werdet ihr auch in den
nächsten lost um den anderen lenzen
folgen hören und zwar durch meine
krankheit also nicht meine krankheit an
ecclestone einfach in paris gelassen
heute wird es hauptsächlich in diesem
snapshot um diesen neuen amboss gehen
kann ich eigentlich nie wieder weg
machen und zwar werde ich einfach mal
direkt anfangen in der letzten snapshot
vorstellung habe ich mich einfach nur
irgend so eine kleine insel gestellt
habt einfach ein bisschen was gequatscht
aber diesmal kann ich euch die
änderungen auch wieder zeigen
also ich habe mich erst mal ein kleines
häuschen gebaut ich weiß es ist sehr
übertrieben und zwar werde ich meine
diamond picknicks erstmal hier
verzaubern hat jetzt an breaking 3 4 und
61 sehr gut jetzt hab ich noch zehn
level und damit werde ich die an nummer
fünf fahrzeugen und die hat jetzt
fischen sie einst einfach dass er hat
nichts mit dem update zu tun allerdings
diese teile das ist der amboss der vize
crafted also drei blog auf ein oben
darunter drei blog auf ihren unten und
in der mitte ein event in gott
hier braucht quasi einfach nur eisen das
ist ein normaler amboss also die findet
sich im decoration spot das ist ein
entweder also ein amboss denke dass ein
slightly damage pendelt also einen
leicht beschädigten amboss und einen
very damage ten will also ein sehr
beschädigten am bus ihr könnt einfach
auf irgendeinem von denen hier rechtsweg
draus machen das ist egal ich mache
einfach mal auf den hier und dort erst
mal meine pack extra ein an breaking
3461 sind 24 levels und jetzt noch eine
vision c1 und da passiert gar nichts
warum nichts passiert das verstehe ich
auch nicht wohin als ich noch geklappt
ich weiß nicht warum wartet vielleicht
liegt es daran dass ich in game ort bin
also ich mache das hier gerade ich zum
ersten mal ich hab mir das gerade beim
dinges durchlesen ich wollte mal ganz
kurz was hier mit ab ja das ist echt
schon extrem krass und zwar habe ich
jetzt mit meiner pictures abgebaut die
ist jetzt ein wenig waha wenig
beschädigt die kann ich nicht einfach da
rein tun da okay jetzt habe ich die
nämlich dort drin und kann jetzt muss
man schon da steht aber tue expensive
als einfach zu viele level sind
das heißt wiederum dass sich weniger
level machen muss das heißt na ja
jedenfalls ist das hier dieser neue
amboss also ich weiß noch nicht ganz
genau worum es darum geht man kann halt
sachen wirklich reparieren und den namen
von diesen dingen verändern also es tut
mir leid dass ich davon noch nicht so
die ganz grosse ahnung hab ich denke ich
werde einfach noch ein extra wieder zum
amboss machen wenn ich genau weiß wieder
funktioniert ich hoffe dass es in ihrem
interesse können einfach mal den wieder
ein daumen hoch gehen wenn ich noch ein
extra video zum amboss machen soll
und naja also derzeit neue kann man
sachen reparieren und so weiter dann
wurden außerdem die level up sounds
verändert und zwar er kriegt man nur
noch level up sounds wenn man über das
sind nur noch alle level alle fünf level
abgespielt sein also passt also 55 das
level 10 bis 15 uhr weiter dann wenn wir
die einstellung hingegen auf options
steht hier nun multiplayer settings
warum das multiplayer settings hinweis
nicht also chat settings multiplayer
setting steht einfach nur multiplayer
settings völlig unnötig weil dort das
meiste dort sind wirklich chat settings
man kann dort auch nun dass kay besitzer
also kann man ausland machen ich habe
kein kate kriegt man wenn man bei
optikern spendet entwickler können in
einer benutzerdefinierten explosions
radios haben und eine xp nutzer
definierte zündung zeit das heißt es
kann sein dass ein krieg war schon
explodiert wenn er dort hinten ist kann
sein dass er hier ist kann sein dass war
zehn sekunden braucht zum explodieren
explodieren kann auch sein dass er nur
zwei sekunden braucht und es kann auch
sein dass er alles in die luft sprengt
also nicht so heftig oder halt nur
seinen kleinen fünf blog oder so eine
kleine blume
naja man erhält nun auch übrigens
erfahrungspunkte für das züchten von
tieren das wollte ich euch jetzt nicht
zeigen weil es ist eigentlich relativ
egal
also habt ihr habt ihre macht dort wie
letzten dass die so ein bisschen vögeln
also nicht vögel filmen sondern auch
schweine vögel und dann geht es da ganz
schön ab und dann kriegt ihr ganz schön
viel erfahrung
außerdem wenn die f3 drückt seht ihr ja
die fw koordinate moment die seht ihr
hier da steht nun f2 north f2 ist also
osten
da wurden nun diese osten und westen und
so hinzugefügt dann übrigens wenn man
shift und dabei f3 drückte es dort
wieder dieser dinge können wieder weg
machen und nur so f3 ist dort nicht
dieser komische kreis vom leuchtfeuer
blog die effekte sind auf dem bildschirm
nicht mehr so aufdringlich also sehr
dezent mittlerweile die effekte das ist
eigentlich ganz cool finde ich und ja da
gibt es auf bugfixes entwurf tränke von
spendern abgeworfen werden geben sie nun
wieder den richtungen effekt ich weiß
nicht
dass da etwas anders war was ich kann es
kurz machen zwar bin ich jetzt langsamer
bzw
moment ich habe wagnis was genau das
bedeutet weiß ich nicht aber auf jeden
fall mir jetzt irgendwie vorbei also die
haben wieder den richtigen effekt und
außerdem gibt es noch die bucks dass ein
amboss wenn in der luft platziert wird
dass ich dann immer dreht aber lebens
ist dass ich schon die 12 341 b und ich
glaube dort ist das schon zeichnet oder
das ist die 240 ps ist dort wurde dieser
bug schon behoben und na ja das was man
von diesem update ich würde mich
definitiv über einen daumen hoch freuen
wenn ich irgendwann auch mal ein video
zum amboss machen soll und dann will ich
sagen sehen uns in der ersten folge